les cadeaux de voisins et d'étrangers
touché par la mort de john floyd temps
de fleurs calvet de manas ghosn a plus
assez vaste pour tout les conserver au
mieux aux jo le flou et des halles
venmar ago habitaient ensemble depuis
quatre ans ils se sont rencontrés au bar
conga ou john floyd assurer la sécurité
de tous rappelle georges floridis y le
divan ou ce géant de six pieds six
pouces regarder le sport à la télé ces
souliers préféré que personne n'a osé
toucher son nom sur la boîte aux lettres
le panier de basket ball avec lequel il
montrait aux jeunes du voisinage a joué
6 go by it would be stories ou bieber
georges tron était venu à minneapolis en
quête d'une vie meilleure pour aider ses
enfants loin de son passé trouble à
houston n'a jamais vu de george frey
toucher à des drogues mais selon le top
6 du coroner des traces de fin d'année
les deux maîtres amphétamines ont été
décelés et si john floyd a vraiment
utilisé un faux billets de 20 dollars
dit-il
ça devait être sans le savoir
en voyant son ami devenir le symbole des
inégalités et du racisme aux états unis
a levé de manas go se consolent douleur
et espoir aussi à houston dans ce
complexe résidentiel violent et
marginalisées où il a grandi georges
klein était un modèle pour les gens
c'est grâce à floyd que de tels
rassemblements sont possibles dans ce
quartier où l'once mifid on peut tout le
monde
il prônait la non-violence et personne
n'osait contredire tout est flou devait
revenir ici dans quelques semaines et
7,7 contre lieu de recueillement à
quelques coins de rue de là son père et
plusieurs de ses clients ont été
victimes de brutalité policière
cet ancien joueur de la nfl devenu
avocat crois que le temps est venu de
changer les lois et d'arrêter protéger
les policiers avoir les centaines de
personnes endeuillées venus rendre un
dernier hommage à georges claude le
message semble avoir été entendu
chez nous et c'était parmi les premières
à faire la file avec son fils de 9 ans
souhaitent un monde plus juste et sans
racisme pour lui
des réformes ont déjà été initiés comme
on exerce avec ce qu'on appellera le
projet de loi jones floyd pour prévenir
la brutalité policière
le gouverneur de l'état promet qu edward
floyd changera le cours de l'histoire
américaine
georges peau est plus qu'un chien d'or
quarts de finale
il ne s'est rendu aux morts en vain sur
tille sa mort semble d'abord l'ancien
mouvement de lutte contre la répression
policière et de racisme comme peu
d'autres auparavant john floyd ira
maintenant rejoindre sa plus grande
admiratrice sa maman si si il sera
inhumé à côté d'elle
demain
ici philippe leblanc radio-canada
houston